[Musique]
hu
le 3 fait quelque chose qu'on utilise
pour soigner depuis déjà très longtemps
de la poche de glace pour arrêter les
saignements et limiter les hématomes ou
grand bain glacé pour favoriser la
récupération des sportifs en passant par
la fameuse bombe magique et depuis
quelques années une solution un peu plus
perfectionnés s'est développée la
cryothérapie le terme cryothérapie ça
vient de cryo qu'ils adorent ça vient du
grec
cryo qui veut dire froid et de thérapie
qui veut dire thérapie soigné par le
froid c'est très utilisé par les
sportifs
je suis à peu près sûr que vous en avez
déjà vu avec un soin genba dafri assez
aléatoire mais mieux qu'un long discours
je vous propose d'aller voir comment ça
se passe en vrai alors là ce dont on
parle c'est de cryothérapie corps entier
c'est à dire que c'est tout le corps qui
est soumis à un froid très intense il en
existe plusieurs formes comme la chambre
cryogénique est une pièce dans laquelle
on fait baisser la température
mais là en l'occurrence c'est un cri you
soon as avant de commencer on a vérifié
que mon état de santé était compatible
avec l'exposition au froid que j'allais
bien au niveau cardiovasculaire que ma
peau était saine et que je n'avais pas
d'allergie au froid l'église a
d'ailleurs au sujet de la peau vous avez
été quelques-uns attiré mon attention
sur la mésaventure des macaques up qui a
été brûlé après une séance de
cryothérapie ce genre de pollen peut
apparaître si une zone de la peau et
humide pour à cause de l'air ambiant
soit parce qu'on a mis une crème
corporelle et ouais parce que je t'ai
humide ça gèle et ce qui gèle ça brûle
donc attention dieu venait à venir
[Musique]
avant de rentrer dans la cabine de
cryothérapie évidemment on change pas on
se met en chaussettes gants et
sous-vêtements pour protéger les
extrémités un peu sensible dans ce temps
là la cabine et préparer la température
à l'intérieur descend sous les 80 degrés
c'est le niveau 1
[Musique]
qui crée le froisser de l'azoté liquide
vous savez comme pour les verrues
attention la l'azoté par en contact
direct avec la peau il est dans un
circuit fermé qui refroidit l'air qui
est ensuite injecté dans la cabine est
ensuite bah y'a plus qu'à y aller
c'est risqué alors je ne vous cache pas
que c'est très vivifiant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui conseille on évite de toucher les
parties métalliques pour part resté
collé une fois qu'on est dans la
température continue à baisser jusqu'à
passer sous les -150 degrés et la séance
dure trois lignes on n'a pas idée à quel
point sa toiture
[Musique]
les premières sensations à part le froid
bien sûr c'est des picotements sur la
peau et puis assez rapidement une sorte
de douleurs au niveau des articulations
notamment celles qu'ont su faire donc là
j'ai déjà les tétons qui pointent la
saône est palpable
adjacent qui se passe des choses aillent
au delà cheville
montre insensible évidemment il ya la
réaction à laquelle vous attendez toutes
et tous donc là mon pénis et une noix de
cajou actuellement
en tennis finalement à quoi ça sert tout
ça et surtout comment ça marche
la cryothérapie essentiellement utilisé
par les sportifs parce que le choc
thermique qu'elle crée favoriserait la
récupération en stimulant la circulation
sanguine et la filtration des toxines
par les rats elle déclencherait aussi
une réaction anti inflammatoire
susceptible d'agir sur les petites
lésions oculaires
la technique est d'ailleurs aussi
utilisé par des patients qui veulent
soulager certaines douleurs chroniques
comme la cud remis à jean par exemple
par le même mécanisme mais aussi en
allant six ans la transmission des
influx nerveux et la conduction de la
douleur alors vous l'avez remarqué
j'utilise le conditionnel la raison est
très simple il n'y a pas de réelle
études scientifiques qui prouvent avec
certitude tous ces phénomènes
ça veut dire que ça marche pas ça veut
juste dire que pour le moment ça n'a pas
été prouvé scientifiquement
mais comme beaucoup de médecins du sport
d'athlètes et de malades ont noté des
résultats positifs
la cryothérapie y ait de plus en plus
utilisés certains instituts de
cryothérapie par le site vertus
amincissantes
ça fait brûler des calories et fond de
mes bourrelets tard avant que chaud aux
fesses
bon sans surprise évidemment c'est pas
la solution miracle ça se saurait là
encore il n'y a aucune preuve
scientifique de l'efficacité de la
méthode est là pour le coup je dis ça
vraiment pour être poli en tout cas moi
j'ai pas vu des faits sur les poignets
j'ai l'impression d'être un jarret de
porc dans un bouillon dernier détail qui
vous intéressent sans doute ça coûte 40
euros la séance
et selon les cas il faut en faire
plusieurs bons globalement pour résumer
l'expérience je dirais que ça ressemble
assez fidèlement à l'idée que je me
faisais de me retrouver à poil par mois
150 degrés mais bon je me suis échauffé
très vite et j'ai même eu droit à un
café
une fois dehors j'ai eu un bon petit
coup de boost 1 avec une furieuse envie
d'aller courir mais quatre heures plus
tard j'ai eu 1
bach c'est normal et c'est non la raison
pour laquelle certains font des séances
pour lutter contre les problèmes
d'endormissement faut juste bien calculé
lors de ce rendez vous alors encore un
peu plus tard je veux pas mentir j'ai eu
des troubles d'ordre digestif
une bonne grosse liasse comme on dit
dans le jargon bon c'est aussi quelque
chose qui peut arriver mais ça passe
vite
ah oui à un moment j'ai dit un truc je
suis presque sûr que ça vous a
interpellé lors du british ben si ça
vous intéresse de savoir pourquoi le
pénis devient un tout petit quand il
fait froid je vous propose d'en reparler
dans une prochaine vidéo
d'ici là mettez vous bien et dans le
même temps par pitié portée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]